i am originally from iran but i've been
in canada for more than 17 years now and
i lived in vancouver for a long time and
recently moved to montreal
my supervisor is dr adjung moon and she
works at mcgill and she heads the
responsible autonomy and intelligence
systems ethics lab is short for race lab
she focuses primarily on human robot
interaction and how we can have better
interaction with robots and how to
collaborate better
i work in the field of ai ethics so the
field basically looks at the social and
ethical implications of ai systems and
how we can have
safe and good interactions between ai
and humans and the society at large
there's different names we use for the
field one of them is also responsible ai
design
[Music]
i would say
between the lines because in the
particular research i look at i look at
how ai systems it could actually fail in
ethical and social ways and a lot of it
is about the reading between the lines
and understanding the details of these
systems and understanding how they can
actually impact people and how we can
actually measure that
and so that we know which failures to
watch out for
and i also
think about different ways of
having controls
that allow us to detect these failures
before they actually happen
and so so we can actually have these
systems working in a way that makes
people happy and also
allows these systems to exist with us
it's great it's a very lively city and
there's a great food and great culture
and a lot of
artsy places to go and check out it's
quite amazing
this is a hard question there's a lot of
people and i won't be able to
sort of capture all of their names here
but tim netgabru is one of the
researchers and activists in the field
that i look up to
i also look up to ryan keller who is a
lawyer in the field and has done a ton
of work in
robotics and
laws and regulations around robots
i also look into up to my supervisor
moon who has basically worked in the
field since the field the name and the
phrase robot ethics was a coined
and and many other researchers it's a
growing field it's quite exciting to be
part of it
so when i wanted to pursue my phd i was
looking for an organization that i
like in terms of how they approach their
work and the values they have and from
all of the different research institutes
that i saw i really i like tamila's
approach and the values that the
organization embraces so that was a key
key element in the choice and i also
had heard about the research community
here the ai research community and i
wanted to get to know
the community here in montreal after
being in vancouver for so long as i was
very excited to come and meet people
here
and
work more